nos dicen que gx es una transformación
de fx que en la siguiente gráfica nos
muestran a fx como una línea sólida azul
aquí tenemos la gráfica de ye igual a fx
iag de x como una línea punteada roja
así es que aquí tenemos la gráfica de
igual a gdx y nos preguntan cuál es la
fórmula de gx en términos de fx y nos
dieron aquí algunas opciones
así es que te recomiendo que le pongas
una pausa del vídeo y lo intentes por tu
cuenta
bueno hay varias formas en los que
podemos tratar de resolver esto ahora si
le echamos un vistazo a esto parecería
como que si tomamos la gráfica de fx y
la reflejamos con respecto al eje de las
x se vería bastante parecida a la
gráfica de gx bueno pero la gráfica de g
si se ve como la reflexión de f pero un
poco más aplastada si es que por ejemplo
si fuéramos a reflejarlo perfectamente
sobre el eje de las x
nos quedaría algo que se ve más o menos
así ok y aquí nada más estoy haciendo un
bosquejo si pudiéramos reflejarlo
perfectamente y bueno yo no lo estoy
dibujando perfectamente pero se verían
más o menos así y bueno para hacer un
poco más claros si esta es la gráfica de
i igual a efe de x entonces esta cosa
que acabo de dibujar por aquí esta línea
sería la gráfica de ye igual a menos
efe de x porque cualquier valor de fx
simplemente tomás el negativo y obtienes
la reflexión de fx a través del eje de
las equis y ahora por otro lado g de x
se ve como una versión un poco más
aplastada de esta reflexión de hecho se
ve más o menos como si fuera una tercera
parte de ésta así es que eso es lo que
yo creo que está pasando
g de x es un tercio de esta otra función
yo creo que quede x es igual a un tercio
de menos
fx lo cual también lo podemos escribir
como menos un tercio de f de x ahora no
está en ninguna de estas opciones lo
cual me hace querer proceder con un poco
más de cautela pero déjame hago énfasis
en por qué me gusta esta opción
pareciera que para cualquier valor de x
g de x es una tercera parte de menos
efe de x por ejemplo aquí en lugar de
llegar a 4 estamos llegando un poquito
más arriba que 1 y luego por acá en
lugar de llegar hasta 3 llegamos más o
menos como al 1 y por acá en lugar de
llegar al 1 estamos llegando más o menos
al un tercio así es que si parece como
que la g de x es un tercio de esta línea
que dibujamos por aquí que es - efe x
entonces si parece como que lage es un
tercio de menos fx o sea menos un tercio
de fx y repito otra vez no es ninguna de
estas opciones pero vamos a ver algunos
valores específicos aquí vamos a buscar
algún lugar donde parezca que
encontramos puros enteros
por ejemplo justo en este punto parece
que tenemos un entero parece que f de
menos 7
efe de menos 7 es igual a menos 1 y
parece como que g de menos 7 este punto
de aquí que de menos 7 es igual a un
tercio claro que esto es simplemente
echándole un vistazo pero es consistente
con lo que tenemos aquí
efe de menos 7 es menos 1 tomamos menos
una tercera parte de eso y nos queda un
tercio pero por supuesto podemos volver
a hacer esto con algunos otros valores
de x por ejemplo si nos fijamos
este punto parece como que efe de menos
uno es igual a menos tres y bueno parece
que g de menos uno es menos un tercio de
esto
ok porque tenemos aquí a g de menos uno
para este puntito de aquí tenemos que g
de menos uno es igual a uno lo cual sí
es menos un tercio de lo que tenemos
aquí así es que me siento bastante
cómoda con esta suposición que hicimos
por acá yo estoy bastante segura de que
ge x si es igual a menos un tercio de fx
y otra vez cuando tomamos a menos
fx lo que estamos haciendo es tomar a fx
pero volteando la y luego la
multiplicamos por un tercio lo cual la
aplasta que es lo que estamos observando
por aquí así es que estoy bastante
segura de que esta es la opción correcta
por lo que voy a contestar que no es
ninguna de las opciones anteriores